[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
season three of call of duty modern
warfare has just landed and with it came
a whole heap of changes not just to the
multiplayer portion of the game but also
my favorite mode warzone some of these
are free to all some are paid for via
the battle pass or full game and there's
also some freebies for PS Plus
subscribers which is nice so to
celebrate the arrival of this new season
and to pass the time while I'm
downloading three million gigabytes of
updates I thought I would take this time
to look through everything you need to
know about season three
let's start with the changes that are
coming to warzone modern warfare is
insanely popular battle royale mode at
the top of the list is quads allowing
you to drop into battle with three of
your brothers in arms' or in fact
actually three random people who
abandoned me the second we jump out of
the plane I need friends this is a huge
deal for warzone players as since launch
we've been stuck with three people in a
group just like apex legends but now we
can go up to a Quad Squad you think it
won't change much but it will tactics
will change angles will be covered and
that extra person in each squad
drastically changes every single battle
season 3 is also the season will be
trialing 200-person lobbies so in solo
games that's potentially 300
eliminations in one game I challenge you
elsewhere new variations of war zones
vehicles have been thrown into the mix
both the ATV and the cargo truck have
been shown and get this with vehicle
skins I was looking forward to a brand
new vehicle but then again I usually see
them just before they plow into me and
murder me happy days as loadout drops
continue to be the name of the game it's
also worth taking note that new weapons
are arriving this season expect to see
two weapons right away a semi-automatic
pistol with a three round burst
attachment and this the SKS a marksman
rifle that focuses on utility / accuracy
and is said to have the fastest rate of
fire than any other marksman rifle both
of these weapons can be found in the new
battle pass at tiers 15 and 31
respectively but here's the main thing
to remember don't worry if you are only
playing the free version of the game
that's completely fine both of these
weapons are on the free track of the
pass this is a big deal as it moves the
game one step further away from that pay
to win model we first heard last month
and that makes me so much happier
everyone is equal if you put the time in
a third weapon class looks to be coming
later in the season but for now the
details just say classifieds thanks Call
of Duty in these very early days of new
weapons dropping you'll never know if
it's for you unless you try them and
then you've got to unlock all the
attachments so yeah it can take a bit of
time before you know if it's a good
weapon for your loadout in fact if you'd
like a video going through all the most
useful ROP loadouts for warzone let me
know in the comments I'll be sure to
make one if you want one of the
multiplayer modes which a drop
throughout the season our sabotage
coming midseason and jug of war coming
around the same time if all goes well
sabotage is an unlimited respawn match
in which players must destroy an
objective in the time allotted a frantic
game mode with zero downsides of dying
whereas jug of war is all about the
sacred juggernaut armored suit our squad
will compete against other squads to
search and obtain the suit but that's
not the end of this one once you've
captured the armor you must wear it and
successfully get this beast to the enemy
stronghold now that does sound fun let's
go back to war zone of course it's not
always about being effective when
fighting it's about looking good while
you're doing it and for that we have
operators there are three new faces to
familiarize yourself with this time
around a quick word of warning though
operators and the various skins are one
of the main ways modern warfare has been
monetized so if you're opposed to
microtransactions then maybe look away
for a minute or two first up it's Alex
or echo 1-3-1 if I remember rightly one
of the main characters for a modern
warfare campaign who is immediately
unlocked on the paid version of the
battle paths as war zone is free to play
many of you won't have actually
experienced the story yet I won't spoil
exactly what happened to Alex but him
being here is a spoiler within itself
and he has a prosthetic leg mmm I wonder
what happened to him in fact I'm going
to make a story breakdown because I
really enjoyed that campaign I'm getting
sidetracked over the course of the
season two more operators will be added
to the mix these are Ronan and Iskra we
don't know their backstory yet but I'm
sure you'll see them shoot you in the
face very soon the season 3 roadmap also
confirms that we'll start to see the war
zone formula getting mixed up a little
bit and some new fun game modes for
example scopes and scatter guns has
already been teased which is a test
version of war zone where you can get
only sniper rifles and shotguns I like
that new twists on battle royale formula
need to keep coming like this it keeps
us all coming back he keeps the game
feeling fresh and it's a good
distraction isn't it
I'll call one now with one day we will
get melee only battle royale I'll still
be the first person to die the
developers have also promised a
continuous overhaul on ground loot as to
try and diversify the strategies
available to players in warzone with new
weapons and blueprints that can appear
supply boxes in fact they've also
confirmed we'll see every weapon type
get its own silenced and non silenced
variants which will suit those who like
to go in loud or keep it stealthy here's
something cool for any PlayStation Plus
subscribers a new combat pack it will
become available alongside season 3
that's open to all players whether you
own the full version of the game or just
the walls on portion it includes an epic
operator skin for Wyatt a couple of epic
blueprints and a few other goodies worth
your time if you're a PS Plus subscriber
this is a no brainer
download it before it vanishes did you
get last season's one good I hope you
did the last thing I've known for
warzone players is of course the
remainder of the new battle pass just
like in season 2 we can all progress
towards the free track don't worry about
it and whether you own the full game or
not you will not need to fork out any
money to access the new weapons paying
upfront though you will of course get
stuff such as Alex but we've talked
about new vehicle skins weapon
blueprints meaning you can see it's
similar variety of rewards to those we
saw in season 2 in total of 150 unique
items although a lot of the things
repeat so they're not unique but
advertising and if you get all the way
to the end you'll have 1300 call of duty
points enough to buy the season for
battle pass nice touch isn't it you pay
for one as long as you play enough
you'll never pay again one new addition
to the battle pass is a series of
operator threads modeled after some
real-world Armed Forces divisions this
includes the u.s. Expeditionary Forces
that how you say it sorry sorry the
South Korean Special Forces and the
counter-terrorist special police boss of
a CT SPF which is a great word in
Scrabble pretty cool for players who
like to go for the realism like
realistic wanted to look like the real
thing and then that teammates praised
them bright pink perfect while all the
weapon operator and battle paths unlocks
carry over between all modern warfare
modes there's still a handful of new
additions that apply to the multiplayer
side of call of duty modern warfare
which is still only available to players
who own the full game you can expect
three new maps including talisca back
lock a remake of the original back lock
map from Call of Duty 4 there's Hovick
sawmill and a near incursion modern
warfare 3 hardhat map has also been
confirmed for later on in the season
alongside a new gunfight map called
aisle nine and finally if you're a
playstation gamer you should know that
all ps4 players will get exclusive
access to a new survival mode map shoot
house before any other platform I always
hated it when Xbox got things early when
I was on ps3 but now for some reason I
don't mind as much does it trigger you
in fact let's just be honest for a
moment what do you think about early
access for single platforms I'm thinking
about making a video on this I'd love to
know your thoughts could you put your
answer below and what platform you're on
thank you very much now back to stupid
voice Adam so there we have it pretty
much everything you need to know about
season 3 in modern warfare and the
changes that have come to both warzone
and the other core game modes if you
enjoyed this video do that like thing
that subscribe thing helps as well but
Ubu I don't I don't mind you live your
life how you live your life I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure enjoy lockdown
see you soon